hello believe nation today we're going
to talk about the seven qualities that
make a great leader so I often get asked
by entrepreneurs how do I be a better
leader how do I be a better guide a
better mentor for my team and still
today I'm going to share with you my
seven ways for you to be a better leader
[Music]
we number one is to have more
self-awareness this is super important
if you want to be able to know how you
can help other people learn grow and
develop you need to first understand
yourself before you can understand truly
understand other people you need to
first understand yourself and so the
path the lens to which I see the world
my path is to finding your one word I
think in order to help other people find
their one word you need to know yours
first you need to understand the type of
people that you want to surround
yourself with you need to understand
what kind of business that you're trying
to create you just understand the
mission the vision that you're on and it
starts with the self-awareness of
understanding your single most important
core value that you want to drive
business growth through if you can't
understand yourself first then you get a
really hard time understanding other
people number two is unlocking their
self learn all the people on your team
if you can help them through the process
of figuring out what they stand for what
their one word is what their most
important core value is then it makes it
easier for them to understand themselves
and for you to guide them and help them
on their path if you know that somebody
really values creativity then it's
looking at how do I give them more
creative path if somebody really values
grit then how do I give them passes they
can grind out for them to understand who
they are then they can carve out a path
for themselves
hopefully inside your organization but
it may also mean that they have to leave
because there's a mismatch of value
their skills may be perfectly aligned
with what you need what their values are
not and so it's not
good long-term fit for your business
unlocking their self-awareness I think
it's one of the greatest gifts that you
can give as a leader because in my view
the role of a leader is to unlock the
potential it's to see people where
they're at now and help them understand
where they can go and help them
understand is the feeling that they have
for themselves are nowhere near the
ceilings that they could actually bust
through so a lot of people feel like
they could be doing more but they don't
know what they should be doing that's
your job as a leader to help them see
that untapped potential and help them
realize it and again for me the start is
understanding the self-awareness
figuring out your one-third number three
is put them first this is really really
really important that one thing that I
don't think enough leaders do my job my
goal my intent
every time I'm meeting with somebody who
looks for me is to put them first I want
to help them as a human being and
ideally it matches up with my company
what I'm trying to do but again it may
not like what they want to do may not be
the best fit for my company I don't want
to hold them back in the position
because it's safe or easy I want them
off doing the thing that makes them come
alive and so this is actually a hard
concept for people understand when they
first sit down with me because it's so
easy for the leader to put themselves
first to see everything through the lens
of the business where I think the great
goal of a leader should be to put your
people first try to help them do what's
best for them that's what gets them to
really open up and tell you and maybe
there's a fit within your organization
or maybe it means they need to leave but
either way in every conversation I'm
trying to help my person grow to the
best of their ability number four is
make a plan when you understand what
they want to do what their goals are
what their ambitions are what they want
to accomplish and you know what their
one word is and you know what their
values are then it's making a plan for
them okay what does the world look like
for you in an ideal spot right like
where do you want to go what are the
next things you want to accomplish in a
1 year 5 year 10 year window what are
the some of the things that you want to
go out there and do and how can I help
you
and helping put some structure around it
so that it's not just some idea that
they have it's helping them create it a
lot of people when they come into your
ghen ization they may not have set goals
for what they want to do right they know
what kind of makes them feel good they
may have a vision for what they want
their life to be but they're afraid to
do it and they don't often have people
in their life to help push them and
guide them and make plans with them they
may not be great at making plans
themselves and there's nobody around
them to help them with that and so this
is your opportunity as a leader to help
them do that and again you're making a
plan is in the best interest of them and
not just you and sometimes that may mean
that you are stepping stone for them
here as an example here at Charlies and
salsa one of my instructors Lily
Seaton teaches the most classes that we
have right now she teaches the most
classes her goal long term is she sees
herself on stage she wants to be a
speaker she wants to be you know
entertaining and delighting and
inspiring audiences that's what she
wants to do I can't provide that within
Charlie dance salsa as a setting I can
give her tools and resources and
knowledge based on what I've done
because I've gone out and done those
speaking engagements but I can give her
a platform here at EDS that becomes a
stepping stone everything that she wants
to learn and go out and stage and do she
can start doing a ton of class you can
start being inspiring she can start
telling stories she can start helping
students that we have coming through
live a better life through dance but at
some point she's going to have to break
free from what she can gain here to go
off and do her own thing
maybe we partner up and it becomes an
adventure I don't know but PDS is a
stepping stone for her and I get that
and I love that like I don't want to tie
somebody down here whose long-term goals
need to be here but if there's a way
that our paths can be mutually
beneficial for a certain amount of time
before they veer off I love that let's
focus on that and so making the plan is
per them and their long-term success and
hopefully some of that relates to your
business and if not push them away one
of my favorite things to do with pushing
somebody away from the business if it
doesn't align with what they want to do
I don't want to hold somebody back here
I want to help
[Music]
number five is give them opportunity to
stretch so when I know what somebody
wants to do and I know what their
one-word value is then I want to find
opportunities for them to be able to
stretch and to grow and to build on that
base so as an example I look at Alex
who's with me here at Toronto dance
salsa his first teaching opportunity
came when he was dancing with Sharon he
was used to sit he was not the
instructor he was just adding a little
bit of advice and feedback in the class
but Sharon was the main teacher
Sharon had an injury and she couldn't
teach the class anymore and she asked me
to come in and teach the class the
challenge is I can't dance with Alex we
don't have two male instructors dancing
together at the front of the class so if
I was going to teach the class I would
need to have a female assistant and then
Alex would be left on the sidelines and
will be able to teach and continue to
grow so I like pushing people I like
giving people opportunities often with
very little preparations to see if
they're going to jump at it or not so
we're driving on the way to our class
and I told Alex in the car Alex we've
got two options here I can either guide
the class I will teach it I will step in
and run the entire night and I'll have a
female assistant and you can be on the
sidelines and help out every now and
then or you could jump in and be the
instructor the role that he wanted to
have but he wasn't ready for was it
stretch and I'll sit on the sidelines
and I'll guide you it in between stats
on every Sun will come on give me
feedback on my tier will help you get
better you're going to make mistakes but
we'll build you up and grow and see what
do you what do you want to do what would
you rather do and he took the shot to
become the instructor and then my role
for the rest of the semester was guiding
him mentoring and training him and so I
love giving stretch opportunities for
people pushing them beyond what their
comfort zone is and my believing in them
as a leader helps them believe in
themselves they may not believe in
themselves an ability to do it but me
saying I think you can do it and I'm
here to help you help push them through
the discomfort to create something
amazing and I think that is one of the
primary responsibilities as a leader is
to help them push through the discomfort
to reach a ceiling that they didn't even
know existed and
let's do it number six is hold them
accountable this as well it's a super
important one because people tend to not
hold themselves accountable enough
people have goals people make plans
people have aspirations people set news
resolution and then they don't follow
through most people don't follow through
on the things that they say they want to
do is important to them if you make a
plan if you understand the person you
understand their one word you women
understand the credo the three things
that make up there one word now you have
the ability to hold them accountable if
you look at why they're not achieving
their plan why they haven't made the
step forward you can look at what the
extend for what is your one word what
are the three things that break it down
it's for example one of them is
creativity okay are you being creative
in your accomplishing distel are you
being creative enough in your work if
one of them is grit you can look at that
and say okay like why aren't you
following through these great as part of
your credo it's part of your one word
you need to stop letting yourself down
like decide that you're letting me down
you're letting yourself down you say
these things are important to you and
you're not living up to them it's
shining a mirror of truth here's the
problem I think most leaders make mostly
theirs assigned their own life their own
values on to somebody else if I really
value creativity and you don't then me
telling you to be creative it's not
going to help you you're going to feel
like you're doing it for me and you feel
you never really fit in and I don't want
you to do anything from me I want you to
do it for you and it helps both of us
you have to ultimately want to do it for
you I'm creating the plan to help you
help you that's it and along the way
that helps me as well mutually
beneficial and so you have to know what
to push people on you have to know where
they are letting themselves down like
figuring out their one word in their
credo so that you have the mirror just
shine up and say this is what you say
you stand for you're letting yourself
down here stop it and they have nothing
to come back to you with because it's
the truth because they realize that they
haven't done what they want to do for
themselves
this is all for them and nobody else in
your life is holding them accountable
that's your job as a leader and number
seven is inspired with your actions so
leaders can come up and give great
speeches and tell people what to do and
tell them why they serve this business
and all of that great stuff and it's
definitely needed sharing the mission
sharing the vision sharing why it's
important sharing the history in the
story and your connection to it is super
important but it's also not enough just
to talk and if you're not great at
talking then it doesn't have to be your
only lever that you can pull you can
inspire with your action I could tell
somebody you need to work hard look you
said working hard as part of your one
word and credo you need to work harder
you're not working hard enough and I can
push them there but I can also model it
they can come in and see me on a
Wednesday shooting 70 videos for the
month and see how I'm working hard your
actions can inspire action you don't
need to be the world's most charismatic
most you know greatest speech writer and
delivery person you don't have to be
Martin Luther King at the front of your
organization rallying the troops if that
is you great lean in on it heavily but
if it's not you don't have to be like
that you can inspire people through the
actions that you take people should look
at you want to be like you they want to
emulate some of those characteristics of
you it's why I started a mentoring
series to try to learn from these super
successful people spend more time with
them so that I could be the best version
of me when I asked the people on my team
at the end of the year what do you want
from me this year how can I be a better
role model guide mentor for you the
number one answer that came back
consistently was just more time they
wanted more time with me so I had to
adjust my schedule to give them more
time they want more time because the
actions are leading to inspired action
on their part so those are my seven
qualities of what I think makes up a
great leader I'd love to know what do
you guys think which qualities did you
agree the most with which qualities feel
like you need to work a little bit more
on and did I miss it eight nine ten that
you want to add to the list leave it
down the comment section
below and will join in the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself in whatever you're
one where it is let's love of these